R
COMING ON "WATTERS' WORLD."
NANCY PELOSI BEGGED THE MEDIA TO
HELP HER SELL THE DEMOCRATS $3.5
TRILLION SPEND BILL.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB MESSAGING?
HOW DO YOU SELL THIS?
>> I THINK YOU ALL COULD DO A
BETTER JOB OF SELLING IT TO BE
FRANK WITH YOU.
JESSE: THE MEDIA CAN'T SAY
WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN THIS THING
BECAUSE IF THEY DID, THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY WOULD WE VOLT.
IT'S STALLED NOW, THANK GOD.
WE'LL START PICKING THROUGH THIS
BOONDOGGLE AND REPORT WHAT'S
TONIGHT.
THE MOST EXPENSIVE BILL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHEN WE BUILT THE INTERSTATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM, THIS IS 8 TIMES
THE COST -- THE COST OF THAT.
THEY WANT HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED
BABYSITTERS.
CRADLE TO GRAVE.
SUBSIDIES TO STAY HOME INSTEAD
OF WORK AND GIVE UNIONS TOTAL
CONTROL OF THE ECONOMY.
LARGEST TAX INCREASE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
$2 TRILLION.
HIGHER BUSINESS TAXES THAN
SOCIALIST EUROPE AND EVEN
COMMUNIST CHINA.
FUMING US BACK TO MORE INFLATION
BRINGING US BACK TO THE CARTER
YEARS.
IT MAKES YOU PAY MORE TAXES
AFTER YOU DIE.
SO YOUR FAMILY DOESN'T GET AS
MUCH.
TAX HIKE ON SMALL BUSINESSES.
TAXES ON ENERGY, TAXES ON
EMPLOYERS.
IF YOU SMOKE CIGARETTES THE COST
OF A PATCH JUST WENT WAY UP.
DOUBLES THE NUMBER OF IRS
AGENTS.
BUT NONE WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
HUNTER BIDEN, JUST THE REST OF
US.
LETS THE AGENTS SPY ON YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT IF YOU HAVE A BALANCE
OVER $600 WHICH IS MOSTLY
EVERYBODY.
THEY JUST HID EVERYTHING IN THIS
THING BECAUSE IT'S TOO TOXIC.
$7 BILLION FOR THE CLIMATE
POLICE.
DEFUND THE REAL POLICE BUT FUND
THE CLIMATE POLICE.
$10 BILLION IN A SLUSH FUND TO
INDOCTRINATE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
REMEMBER OBAMA TRIED GREEN JOB
TRAINING AN BIDEN COULDN'T POINT
TO A GREEN JOB HE CREATED.
$27 BILLION FOR A GREEN BANK.
WE ARE GETTING RIPPED OFF.
THIS IS WHERE DONORS GO FOR
CHEAP LOANS.
FORCES AMERICANS TO USE WIND AND
SOLAR IN PLACES WHERE IT ISN'T
VERY SUNNY OR WINDY.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY DID THIS AND
IT CAUSED ROLLING BLACKOUTS.
THEY WANT TO TURN AMERICA INTO
CALIFORNIA.
NO, THANK YOU.
WE WOULD LIKE TO KEEP OUR LIGHTS
ON.
BILLIONS IN KICKBACKS FOR GREEN
DONORS AND ACTIVISTS.
$20 BILLION FOR DESERT FISH.
I DIDN'T KNOW THEY HAD FISH IN
THE DESERT.
AND $25 BILLION FOR MUSSELS.
A $4 BILLION SLUSH FUND FOR
RADICAL ACTIVISTS TO TEAR DOWN
RACIST INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE TAXPAYER FUNDED
STATUE TOPPLING.
MAYBE THE GEORGE WASHINGTON
BRIDGE IS COMING DOWN.
IT MAKES CROSSING THE BORDER
MUCH EASIER AND HARDER TO DEPORT
ILLEGALS AND SPEND $100 BILLION
TO GIVE AMNESTY TO ILLEGALS.
FREE TAX CREDITS AND WELFARE FOR
ILLEGALS.
AND BIDEN WONDERED WHY ILLEGALS
ARE COMING HERE.
$7 BILLION FOR IVY LEAGUE
SCHOOLS.
THE HEALTHIEST IN THE COUNTRY.
THE WORD EQUITY PLASTERED ALL
OVER THIS THING.
THAT MEANS REVERSE RACISM.
A QUARTER TRILLION TO BAIL OUT
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
DIDN'T WE GIVE THOSE GUYS A
TRILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR?
FREE HOUSING FOR CONVICTED
FELONS.
BEAT YOUR WIFE?
HERE IS SOME RENT MONEY.
PENALIZES GETTING MARRIED.
KEEPS SINGLE MOTHERS ON SUCTION
DIFFICULTIES.
GRANTS TO TREAT PEOPLE FOR
LONELINESS.
I'M SORRY, BUT I'M NOT PAYING
FOR SOMEONE TO FIND DATES.
THERE IS AN APP FOR THAT.
LET'S BRING IN THE SENIOR
ADVISOR TO FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP, STEPHEN MILLER.
THEY DON'T WANT US TO KNOW
WHAT'S IN IT.
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
I WILL GIVE FRIENDLY ADVICE TO
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL.
YOU CAN'T JUST KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THE PRICE TAG.
YOU HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
POLICY INSIDE OF THE BILL.
IT'S 2,400 PAGES FOR A REASON.
IF YOU WANT TO SPEND A FEW
TRILLION YOU COULD DO THAT IN 50
PAGES.
THISN'T LIKE A STIMULUS BILL
WHERE YOU ARE FUNDING PROGRAM.
YOU ARE REORDERING ALL OF
SOCIETY.
THIS BILL REQUIRES HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS TO BE TRAINED IN
EQUITY.
WHICH IS CODE WORD FOR CRITICAL
RACE THEORY.
YOU ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL WITH A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY.
YOU WILL NEED A TRACHEOTOMY, THE
NURSE WON'T BE TRAINED ON AIRWAY
OBSTRUCTION.
THIS BILL IS MADNESS.
IT'S BASICALLY THE GREEN NEW
DEAL COMBINED WITH CRITICAL RACE
THEORY COMBINED WITH MASSIVE
AMNESTY AND OPEN BORDERS,
COMBINED WITH THE COMPLETE
DESTRUCTION OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
THERE IS THE DEATH TAX IN HERE.
TAX CREDITS FOR RICH PEOPLE TO
GIVE MONEY TO THEIR FAVORITE
UNIVERSITIES, PRESUMABLY TO
TEACH MORE CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
I COULD GO ON.
JESSE: YOU ARE SO RIGHT.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE THING.
IT'S EVERYTHING A LIBERAL WANTED
TO DO.
WE GOT THE GREEN NEW DEAL, WE
HAVE AMNESTY.
THEY SHOVED EVERYTHING INTO ONE
PIE.
AND NOW WE ARE ARGUING OVER A
PRICE TAG BUT WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE INGREDIENTS.
THESE INGREDIENTS WILL MAKE
PEOPLE SICK.
>> IMAGINE YOU WENT TO A
RESTAURANT, THEY OVERCHARGED YOU
MASSIVELY.
BUT THEY ALSO POISONED YOU AND
YOU SPENT A MONTH IN THE
HOSPITAL.
IF YOU WROTE A YELP REVIEW,
WOULD IT BE IT WAS AN EXPENSIVE
MEAL?
OR WOULD YOU SAY, THEY POISONED
ME.
GOP, WAKE UP, TELL PEOPLE WHAT'S
IN THE BILL.
JESS